haley bieber is getting real about
supporting her husband justin bieber
throughout his sobriety journey yeah so
during the most recent episode of the
victoria's secret voices podcast the
model opened up about how her experience
growing up with her father stephen
baldwin and navigating his substance
abuse gave her the tools to help justin
there's a lot of addiction that runs in
my family like not even just my dad a
lot of other people on that side of my
family
struggled with a lot of different things
and
my dad was always really open about that
and i always appreciated that i i was
always really really close to my dad and
i was a lot more open with him in a lot
of ways than i was with my mom
i think him being really open about it
and how it almost you know ruined his
relationship with my mom and how they
could have ended up not together and i
think when you're like a teenager and
you're thinking like wow like there's
this thing that was so powerful that
like
my beautiful parents almost like didn't
end up together because of this and he
was just always like extremely open
about like why being sober was
what worked for him and like why he
needed to be sober and what um you know
alcoholic behavior looks like and
where that comes out
i was curious whether you growing up
around
you know recovery alcoholism and
sobriety had given you an insight into
being able to support your your husband
on his journey
yeah i i mean i think so i think even
just
being able to like talk through it with
my mom or i think even just the open
dialogue okay where are you at with this
being able to be honest like
if i ever felt like i got i think like
i've i would have had times and i've had
times where i would get like nervous
like are you okay to do this
because you did have a time in your life
where it was
not okay it was not okay for you and it
was like a dark time for you but
he has very good self-awareness when it
comes to that and is is
very open about it and i think that
is all i can really ask for
of course haley's appearance on the vs
voices podcast shouldn't come as a
surprise to anyone as she just recently
announced her new partnership with the
lingerie brand yeah haley officially
joined victoria's secret versus
collective an initiative that replaces
the brand's traditional angels with a
diverse powerful and inspiring group of
women so of the other models uh it
includes megan rapino and priyanka
chopra okay so where do you want to go
first
oh i mean well i mean
it didn't seem like she was prepared for
that question i think that is a very
personal and a deep question and i can
tell by the way that she answered it
she was hesitating um because it was
gonna turn into a headline and we were
gonna talk about it um but i think it's
interesting you know when you've
witnessed substance abuse in your
childhood if not careful and not healed
you can easily
mirror that continue the cycle in your
romantic uh relationships you know the
wrong men will trigger your wounded
child like all those things are very
real things when you've experienced
substance abuse and from what she said
it sounded like she got a positive
picture on some level of sobriety and
being close to her dad and being able to
talk to her mom with about justin and
what they're going through um i would be
curious for her to share those tools and
how she navigated um sobriety and just
her understanding of it
i think that she has a huge platform and
probably can do a huge amount of good
with it
but it was cool that she opened up i
just don't think she was prepared
she seemed unsure
yeah and to be so open about kind of uh
how devastated she was that her parents
marriage didn't work out you know we all
have those moments where you see your
parents as actual people and you're like
wait no i'm not ready for that um so i
think that was that was great that she
opened up like that you're right uh that
that she's being very vulnerable i don't
know she was ready for that um but you
know you have to say when you look at
justin bieber you look at his career i
mean he's always produce great music but
he seems really happy that seems to
really click something for him when he
married haley they've both been really
open too but that first year of marriage
was really tough they had to figure out
their group whether that had to do with
substance abuse and she was helping him
through that
or just not being young and having
millions of eyes on you and judgment um
but
justin just seems really happy and i'm
like i'm really happy for them as a
couple
yeah and also just like child stars
people don't understand what that is
like and the things that come with that
it's very difficult to navigate your
awkward stage and just discovering who
you are publicly when people are
projecting and telling you who you are
um so just than even having any issues
or any flaws at all is totally
understood when you have that type of
magnitude of fame and then to marry
someone like haley who comes from a
family that is famous i think that they
have a lot to relate uh with and i just
appreciated her sentiment when she said
that justin is very self-aware yeah and
she asked some questions like are you
good like that type of stuff is really
cool and it's interesting to see where
victoria's secret is going right now
with this rebrand because you know
obviously savage ex fenty rihanna's been
really
showing what inclusivity looks like with
runway shows and fashion especially with
lingerie and i know that she's been
slapping victoria's secret over the head
the last few years so um it's been
interesting to see victoria's secret
make their rebrand happen i'm curious to
see how it's going because you know
having a celebrity like haley bieber
attached seems like more of the same but
um having these conversations and adding
priyanka and i saw there are more really
cool names curious to see how far
they're going to take it yeah i like it
so far we'll see yeah we'll see i think
that's such a great way of saying this
is a great you know if we're gonna have
more conversations like that that's
attached to victoria's secret yeah right
but yeah we have haley bieber uh
attached to anything
that's a good thing for brand they you
know she's super popular oh yeah
hopefully yes we'll see more diversity
and i'll be happy with that
yeah and aj is saying often when celebs
are so open it's strategically done not
surprised and good for her to be so open
so there you go